Skål!
here i was still feeling a bit unsure about the timing of what i was doing i was thinking about
how you guys were leaving the room and then here i felt that my foot was slipping
when i first kicked i that made me a little nervous here i was mostly in the zone because
i like front kicks and here i was thinking about how i don't want to step off the mat
and during this moment um i didn't punch my hand hard enough and i was thinking about
how that wasn't very good and here i was thinking about my positioning and how i would get back
to my original spot
and here i knew my hand knives were a little rough so i was nervous about doing them and
when i ended i i was thinking about how uh if i need to finish my whole um bow